this is with your seven of the default
series and that it first wraps up the
name so and then goes to some other
subjects of d4 Knight f6 we were at
exactly this point the black recaptured
with a knight on d5 now it's an
important moment because he three years
son is hanging here and the next month
is is really essential white cannot
really protect this pawn in a
comfortable way he liked it we would
like to do so to protect and keep the
scent of it there's no decent move to do
so just for instance um let's say white
play something like Bishop b2 in order
to follow up with you form then like
just grab the pawn here f3 of course you
always need to keep in mind that there's
a check and other moves are have been
tried for instance on Queen Queen d3 has
been tried I would favorite of shear
offs but this seems to be okay for black
um yeah the main move with DC 5 p.m.
which might look a bit awkward at first
because it really breaks up White's pawn
structure but on the other hand you need
to keep in mind that white actually
obtained the two bishops and the two
bishops of course like open lines and in
this case it's it's really the best move
you can play in the position not like
almost no all games goes from Queen
Queen a5
other possibility here is f5 very
specific line you're only likely to fail
to face it well as some people who
really studied this in some detail ideas
to actually
fight against you for because the the
simple approach like II for fef II like
have got the annoying shaky and here's
the the old trick
getting the look on each one so I'm
white needs to react somehow and that
different approach that I think there's
more than one approach that's
interesting um one could be a form F 2
XE form and Quincy to this is one idea
and I think there's also some other
tries on f5 for France and I think also
night h3 is a possibility but I'm not
100% sure I think the main move is in DD
4 and then they're putting the Queen
there to try to recapture later I think
white what should be slightly better
than this line um Queen f5 is explode as
plate and most often here um now he form
and now black has got a choice where to
put the night one move that's actually
really bad it's capturing capturing him
because Queen Queen e2 puts up nasty
pins threatening but should be too
and also keep in mind you 7 a thing so
this is very bad for black and also that
cannot capture on c3 with the Queen
simply because of Bishop t2 so this is
very nice position black now has to
decide if he goes to e7 or f6 it leads
to the same structure there's some
differences but it's the same pawn
structure let's have a look at 97 um now
white goes simply Bishop e3 it doesn't
mind that sees Rhys hanging the CC you
see three porn
it's not that important in this position
that's more important to of course to
keep the c5 pawn because this spawn well
being structurally we
also it has got some very useful
functions it serves as yeah help for
putting a piece on d6 which is a weak
square likes camp and also one black eye
one move that black often plays for us B
7 B 6 to get some space here and this of
course is it's not prevented by the porn
but it's working against B 7 B 6
um so here black just castles it's it's
really a bad idea to grab this porn
white happily puts the king of men on f2
so nice square for the King you don't
need to castle and you will simply win a
couple of Tempe later with white maybe
92 or rather moves to to gain time on
the Queen
so like Justin goes for development now
Queen B 3 yeah highlighting you've got
two bishops and you got you have a got
an extra pawn it's it's not the greatest
sin porn ever but you've got an extra
pawn and White's ideas to restrict like
further put some piece on these six
maybe or play play on the Queen side
with a space advantage a black now
retreats to c7 we're following a game
here which was played I think last year
was it last year it's not too long ago
maybe it was a 2011 game of thumb vision
and whether some one how the top Chinese
player also rated far above 2700 um
white went to Bishop b5 not ec6
I just want to illustrate a very nice
idea that are not put into effect in
this game
in five castles there should be six and
this was was played before this game so
what next move was really a theoretical
novelty and one arm lady is night to d4
which is really an awesome move
well it just puts a piece on a defendant
Square defendant bad porn it's it's
really immensely strong I think a black
doesn't have much opportunity to to you
have to deny the sacrifice because if if
he doesn't take what might even go
Knight f5 to d6 if you look at this
position why it's problem piece is
actually the night on e 2 it doesn't
have much to do here because d4 and f4
is covered not g3 it's also not a great
idea but this is just just a great move
black took the night and then see from
and now white has just a great position
it's got two pawns remember you you have
an extra pawn to begin with in this line
and now you got two pawns healthy pawns
now and the D pawn is just immensely
strong threatening to really go through
the whole board here
white still has got the two bishops and
black has got well undeveloped pieces or
pieces that are very likely to be pushed
let respect for them and I'd won a very
very nice game here I think it is very
much recommended to to study some games
to get some idea about this structure
because I think this whole line with
with dc5 willow cob pretty often people
actually very often know that d5 is the
best move or the most common move and
we'll play this but they often like
further further knowledge so my
experience is that you very often
actually
this structure which I already briefly
mentioned in the in the last video and
it really pays off to study the
structure as well because you get it
very often and if you do some serious
study here it really pays off because
white very often gets really strong a
tech going later with mobile center if
for you note that's this whole setup
with Bishop b3 and 92 and f3 it's a bit
similar to the setup we discussed
against the Queen's Gambit exchange
variation so the idea of this repertoire
is a little bit - to get similar ideas
and structures so very often white uses
the idea of f3 and pushing for later
it's also what attracted me to to
suggest the line f3 in the first place
because it's a little bit similar in
ideas - to the other lines yeah okay I
think really recommended to study this
structure happening after black captures
with the pawn and then study the
structure with a broken with a broken um
with the broken white pawns but with the
extra pawn and have a look at typical
middle games maybe you're even lucky to
repeat an on speaker files with with 94
actually in this in this line 94 is not
a completely new idea it has been played
in in similar positions before so it
might be possible if you if you look a
little bit more closely at some lines -
to find similar ideas in another move
orders and I think it really pays off -
to study this this line it's pretty
aggressive and it's um not so much well
known in comparison to for instance
Queen c2
I think against Queen c2 everyone has
got some something we worked out because
it is played so often and this I think
well people have some general idea but
they don't know it's really in in much
detail
well I think it it pays off to study
games I already mentioned this and well
I think really a lot of top players and
have played f31 play I also like to
mention who's really got huge experience
there is another Russian player and
Sergei walk off I think he's a two-time
Russian champion always rated something
to 650 or or similar and he played this
line I don't know 50 60 70 times really
lots of games and as interesting to
study his games because it's a it's a
very very fighting player very
uncompromising and sometimes very
original so it's maybe interesting to to
to borrow so to say some ideas that he
used in in his games um yeah I think
that's a term for the names oh and
further videos of course will um address
other lines like him Kings Indian Guin
felled bank or Volga gambit there's a
lot of other stuff to discuss but I
think the name is always really an
essential part as I mentioned f3 is my
suggestion but if you dislike the kind
of structures of course here you are
free to to choose other moves as there
are no huge interferences with with
other lines suggested in the in the
repertoire yeah thanks for watching